let's talk about kajillionaire um this
is a very
uh unusual and i mean that in a good way
movie it's very
uh distinctive your character
is i mean maybe you could why don't you
describe
your character's old dolio well first of
all the hair
over i can almost do it now because i've
grown out my hair i see that
but you have hair over your face a lot
of the time
and then your movements um
i mean you're a very gifted actor so i'm
not surprised that you can do this but
your movements are very distinctive and
almost look like
you you had to really think about how
this character moves
100 uh miranda july uh the director and
i
would get together and uh do strange
exercises and improvs to try to find the
physicality
we end up actually drawing a lot from
animals weirdly
um and and then so when people say what
did you base this character on i say a
proud lion
who became our our our sort of blueprint
for her
that's so interesting because um though
i'm not an actor when i started doing
uh the talk show many many years ago i
was thinking about
what who is who what do i want to embody
and i came up with
scared lemur you know just like
just kind of like wide-eyed nervous
uh somewhat bird-like so i i'm familiar
with nailing it
[Laughter]
only i've been doing it for 27 years and
everyone's like
enough enough you know there's a your
your um really impressive moment
in the film where you're sort of your
character is very sneaky has to be
because you really have to live by your
wits and your ability to
get around situations there's this scene
where you bend backwards and i thought
is that
cgi was that cgi when your character
old bends backwards no in fact
this happens to me a lot in my career um
like
i i on uh the show i do westworld yeah
uh
tiny show that i do um yeah i never
heard it
never heard of it um like i had to ride
a horse
at full speed with while shooting a
rifle so riding
riding on a running horse with no hands
holding this like
heavy rifle and i and i really did it
and everyone
thought it was cgi or thought i was
strapped to the horse and i was like no
and now with kajillionaire they think
that this is cgi or that i was under
wire and i'm like no i'm
look i am actually doing doing these
things with my body
i'm actually doing this um it's not cgi
um
so how do you that was a weird skill is
that is that
yoga years of yoga do you did you have
no did you have like your spinal column
like a few vertebrae removed how do you
do that
okay i don't know why but i've weirdly
been somewhat of like a limbo
uh champion as as a child and growing up
i was i was always the one at
bar mitzvahs that won whatever weird
hat or prize you know if you could do
the limbo challenge and so i don't know
why it's just a strange skill that i
have that
okay now has become immortalized and in
this film
i love that i love that you you brought
up all my life i've been a limbo champ
when never in my life have i been asked
to do limbo
it's where in the world are you living
that
you go to events and people like well
it's limbo time
well growing up as a kid it's like birth
in the 90s i don't know birthday parties
bar mitzvahs
weddings just weird weird things like
that yeah limbo